[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 138 of
our currently daily Google cloud
platform podcast my name is Mark Randall
I'm here with my colleague as always
Melanie work day to day two of next day
to have next indeed it's been pretty
great yeah it has been it's been a busy
day lots going on here lots and lots
going on so we've got a bunch of
interviews happening today with people
here on the show floor and next but what
exciting things have you've been
particularly excited by in the keynote
today the rotating stage platforms
that's what I've been excited about
dating containers everything from
containers in container exactly some of
the announcements are around edge
computing and specifically edge TP use
and cloud IOT edge which i think is kind
of exciting that's pretty cool i really
like cloud armor i think that looks
really great I wish they spelled armor
with you but it's fine I'll live with it
yes so that's a DDoS and application to
vent systems services with geo based
access control which is really sweet
nice and there's additional information
out there about tightened security keys
Fido security key with firmware
developed by Google to verify its
integrity keys from last year I don't
know yeah also there's a whole bunch of
stuff container registry vulnerability
scanning I'm particularly excited about
that so we have integrated stuff for
when you have containers we do security
scanning so we can see if there's
anything that should need to be fixed
and stuff it's very important mark I
think we got a bunch of people we're
gonna chat with today so let's go do
that let's go do it so we're happy to
have join us haben Girma who is an
advocate for accessibility in tech and I
know having you're here with us at next
you just gave a talk on accessibility in
tech not too long ago thank you for
being part of the podcast absolutely
it's an honor to be here so my name is
haben Girma and I am deafblind I have
limited mission and hearings I can use
technology when it's designed
accessible and it's my hope to teach
more developers how to design products
and services that are accessible so we
have recorded a full interview with you
which will be coming up soon yes but to
tease a little of what we talked about
previously could you tell us a bit about
what you talked about here at Club next
the main takeaway from my presentation
this morning is that developers have the
power to build services that everyone
can access a lot of people assume that
people with disabilities don't use
computers or don't use smartphones and
ignore the disability community when
building services don't make those
assumptions designed with everyone in
mind there 1.3 billion people with
disabilities around the world
we're the largest minority group people
who invest in accessibility get to tap
into this large market so it's more
business more revenue in the long run it
means design with access in mind so I
want to encourage everyone to stop
thinking about disability as charity
instead think of it as a business
opportunity what's your favorite
technology and that's accessible and
also just a technology everybody's using
I'm a huge fan of the iPhone because it
has accessibility built in that lots of
people with disabilities and
non-disabled people can use so mobile
phone usage in regards to what type of
aspects work best for you so with my
phone I now have easy access to
communicate with people before that
before I couldn't text and without the
ability to text if I'm traveling around
and need to talk to someone get
environmental information maybe an
emergency alert I wouldn't be able to
get that
but now because I have a smartphone with
accessibility Middleton I have access to
emergency alerts to fund conversations
to restaurant reviews and I have so much
more freedom now with an accessible
phone than I did before accessible
phones were available what are some
resources and outside organizations that
you would recommend for people to check
out if they are interested in
understanding how to be better in
designing accessibility intact
accessibility so you're welcome to check
out my website haben Girma comm some
local organizations San Francisco
Lighthouse for the Blind you can also
check out the National Federation of the
blind and a fedora or the National
cessation of the job there are lots of
organizations that can help provide
information on accessibility what's been
your favorite thing at next so far I
love meeting people I've had the
opportunity to meet lots of cool people
here excellent
well haben thank you so much for joining
us on the podcast today and look forward
to listening to the full episode that'll
come out later in the next few months so
we're excited to have join us parish
Correa great he is from Nvidia and thank
you for coming to join us today thanks a
lot for having me so tell us a little
about who you are and what you do over
in Nvidia sure
so I'm Peniche Kari are responsible for
product marketing for our data center
products nice fantastic and I know
you're here today and Vidya is here
today there's there's a big video
presence can you tell us about what
that's all about yeah sure so my company
Nvidia invented the GPU 2 decades ago
that basically revolutionized the modern
computer graphics yes and also
revolutionized parallel computing more
recently deep learning powered by the
GPUs have been responsible for
advancements in artificial intelligence
and we are very happy about that
GPU computing is also available
across all the different computing form
factors from desktops to devices to
servers to cloud services from our
partners like Google you're here at next
because you had a big announcement
yesterday can you tell us a little bit
about that yeah sure we were very
excited about that
so we announced that our Tesla p4 GPUs
are coming to Google cloud platform p4
is basically a small form factor highly
specialized for AI inference workloads
GPU and while our GPUs flagship GPUs
like V 100 have been available for a
while Google is the first cloud platform
to make p4 available on a global scale
and this speaks to the tipping point of
how AI inference is becoming really
important as a workload the people is
ideally suited for the real-time
inference workloads that require really
fast processing so think of services
like speech based interfaces or
real-time live translations
understanding of video and so on before
can process AI workloads that are really
complex 40 times faster than what's
possible on CPUs alone that's fast well
you probably heard us talk about this in
the past in regards to inference and
training but press do you mind
explaining just briefly what is
inference yeah that's a great question
so training a neural network is when
you're basically pumping in a lot of
data to help a neural network learn by
taking a look at the data and the labels
that are associated with data so that's
the training step it's computationally
very complex inferences when you're
putting that train the neural network to
work so it looks at new data and it
makes predictions so for example if it's
about recognizing speech it's taking in
a new spoken sentence and it's able to
recognize it so that's the ai inference
that's really great we should make note
that we have episode 119 where we talked
to Brian Cannizzaro from Nvidia talking
about deep learning as well so people
want to hear more about that kind of
thing as well agree definitely well what
do you enjoyed what have you enjoyed or
seen so far that you've
been excited about outside of the
announcement here absolutely so one of
the really exciting things for me
personally is Google's pioneering use of
artificial intelligence in adding magic
to your services like magic exactly
whether it's the G suite or optimizing
the performance of your data centers
massive data centers and Google is not
just keeping its technology to itself
it's basically making it available to
everyone every industry and enabling
them to be transformed by AI Google and
NVIDIA we have a strong partnership and
we both understand the need for
accelerated computing to help advance AI
and Google continues to invest in TP use
for example but at the same time Google
is also relying on GPUs to power its own
internal AI as well as they are making
it available as a cloud service on the
Google cloud platform so every deep
learning framework and the diversity of
modern AI can be supported that's great
well we appreciate you coming by to chat
with us on the podcast anything else you
wanted to mention before we let you go
yeah it's it's a it's a really exciting
time we are witnessing a new revolution
in terms of artificial intelligence and
what it can do to revolutionize the
workflows and simplify our lives as well
as revolutionize industries and we just
add the tipping point right now where
people are realizing all of this is
possible be very happy to work with
Google to make our GPU computing
technology available through the Google
cloud platform to help companies and
industries transform themselves
fantastic well thank you so much for
coming to join us here on the next
sharon floor okay thank you I appreciate
it so joining us are ruta gulnur car and
we have Xiamen zeltser and we're gonna
talk a little bit about what's being
presented in regards to window sequel
server and dotnet workloads on GCP so
thanks for joining us thanks for having
us glad to be here excellent do you want
to tell us a little bit who you are and
what you do here at Google sure so I'm
Simon Salter I'm the
programs engineer focusing on work loads
of Windows and dotnet running on GCP hi
I'm Albert I'm a product manager on
Google compute engine and I own making
sure that windows and sequel server
workloads work well on the platform
great well what are you all excited
about in regards to next lots of stuff
there are so many things to be excited
about yeah what are a couple in
particular around the whole windows
sequel server and network loads so first
is you know we're really excited about
the fact that you know we have amazing
amount of migration tooling support
available for lift and shift workloads
there are some really cool demos about
bellows Strada a company that we
acquired recently and that also has a
lot of support for Windows workloads
especially we're also really really
excited about all the support that we
have for dotnet containers which are
running on gke and GAE and there's a lot
of buzz around gke and a lot of support
for running workloads in a modernized
fashion on Google cloud so we're excited
to share Simon's gonna be demoing some
stuff can I show you how you can take
your legacy applications into the new
world so we're really excited to show
some of those capabilities
what do you demo examine I'm going to
demo two things first is how we can lift
and shave legacy dotnet application into
Google cloud as is and then the second
demo is going to be about modernization
of that application splitting the
monoliths into micro services and then
running it in dotnet containers from
Linux on Jiki and also we have a preview
of stock driver debugger which allows us
to do snapshot debugging of our dotnet
workloads in production which is really
really cool that's great well so any
places that people can go look for you
know in regards to additional resources
for Windows sequel server and the dotnet
workloads
yeah absolutely so we have two sessions
that are gonna happen on day one there
is session number one at 3:15 it is
around Active Directory and we have a
customer Capital One who's gonna come
and showcase how they brought their
workloads to GCP we also have a
follow-up session at 4:35 where Simon is
going to do the demo that he just talked
about and we're gonna talk about all the
platform features that you have on
support for
no sequel server and network loads we
also have you know a boot where we're
going to have a dotnet experts to come
and talk to us and we have a ton of
information on our websites so go to
cloud.google.com / windows
cloud.google.com slash sequel server
dotnet and so on and so forth and we
have a page with a lot of resources and
links out there great fantastic is there
anything else we've missed that you want
to make sure that people want to know
about well come talk to us we will be
hanging out and we're excited about all
the new stuff to show you great well
thank you both for joining thanks for
having us
Thanks so we have two completed students
from whole but in school yeah Henry -
and Isaac Wong joining us today
Henry how you doing good doing great
thanks for having an excellent I said
how are you doing doing wonderful
wonderful so why don't you tell us a
little bit about ho button school and
your experience there hole Burton school
is a two-year college alternative
training software engineers it's pretty
much project-based there's no
instructors and it's just peer learning
and project-based to kind of try to
emulate and more realistic approach to
learning as opposed to just giving you
assignment so that you do it yeah it's
also has a deferred - which in model so
we don't pay anything until we get jobs
almost like a big job they didn't pay us
we paid a school back you know for
training it's nice what are some of the
things you're studying so we start off
primarily by doing low level programming
learning old school C and then after
that we do a data for about three months
and then we progress on to higher-level
languages like Python and JavaScript and
then we also look do some DevOps
training also to learn Linux and bash
shell scripting and then make some full
stack web apps so that's the broad
overview of condensing yeah so like I'm
actually in class right now and
yesterday I was working on a my sequel
project to make it back end for Aaron
B&B clone and so it's ramping towards to
doing like DevOps sre kind of work there
but this is very interesting contrast
so speaking we are here what have you
seen what has been particularly exciting
to both of you I come from my healthcare
background so when I saw the the speech
that they were giving yesterday about
how they're leveraging cloud technology
to kind of improve patient treatment
that was very interesting to me
especially since I'm kind of trying to
see if I can still translate some of my
domain knowledge in the healthcare
sector into technology work so hearing
about that that was that was very
interesting to me
on a less serious note I'm also kind of
a gamer so when I went up there and I
saw what they were doing with this
little dancing robot and then they also
showcasing some of the games that's made
in unity now which apparently
transitioned from AWS to two classes
that I was really awesome so you said
mark knows a little bit about that today
that you're specifically supporting you
want to talk about that for a second
yeah so I'm doing there's actually going
to be a gaming Meetup birds of a feather
conversation happening at 4:00 p.m. on
Moscone - it'll be this afternoon so if
you're listening to the podcast
unfortunately this is no use to you but
you should talk to the people who went
anyways well so I know when we were
starting out the podcast you both were
sharing some interesting knowledge I
think would be very useful for others
who go to conferences what are some best
practices on gathering swag okay so if
you're a shameless poor student like
Henry and I what you do when you go to
conference you find a booth that has
swag bags you know those fancy bags yeah
and then you use that bag to go around
to other booth to get like you know
candy chocolate pens
you know robust trinkets that you like
that you can show around from the
conference yeah so and then what most
people are very willing to give away
candy like I think that offering a small
bowl to candy here as long as you ask
for it you're fine taking if you just go
over there except pouring the whole
candy into your bag it's not so nice
just ask Isaac what cool stuff of you
you found particularly yeah so um I
might be naive I was really interesting
when they announced the gke on purim
server yeah yeah I thought that was
really cool I'm not too involved in
that's a recon work if that that seemed
like a very nice innovation there and
I'm really interested to see how that
develops and you're right it is a very
cool innovation and so me personally on
it so Henry from the healthcare
background I'm actually from the
agricultural rec
and so I think that I'm not sure today
tomorrow but I'm interested in session
tomorrow by companies trying to
incorporate machine learning in the
field agriculture to see how that Vince
is that excellent have you ever been
going to sessions while you're here as
well I plan to go to more of it today
after this I'm gonna make a brand what
session do you planning on going to well
I want to try to get some of them what
that's great okay he's planted no in any
particular gaming sessions you want to
go to I saw that they had the booth he
had a dancing robot one I didn't
actually get to see in session like I
was kind of waiting but then I saw what
they were showing the Dauntless
the showcase and then so like I got to
talk to Terry and he was explaining to
me and I learned a lot about how
container is actually in virtual
machines being used to run the
matchmaking servers and then stuff like
that in the background so I was like
really interesting wait there's a
dancing robot how did I know they have a
really amazing exhibit up there where
they've got an animator here and I think
the other animators in LA oh wow and
they're doing like live animation stuff
on the show floor and then and that's an
entertainment side it's it's really cool
I mean I didn't want to go - I went to a
tensorflow
session earlier today it sounds like I'm
really just in machine learning I just
don't know anything about it so I'm here
to learn about it so that was really
interesting good reason to be here yeah
yeah I mean I always intimidated because
like you know going through the whole
session list there's a whole bunch of
things which I don't know about but it's
nice that they have like introductory
sessions like that for people like me to
go to I went to the hands-on lab - again
another good introductory session - for
people who don't know any about the
Google products and that's like machine
learning attempted flow things like that
so that was cool everybody start
somewhere so that's great that you're
doing that yeah well thanks guys we
really appreciate you coming in to share
with us your experiences about next
thank you thank you for having us thanks
thanks everybody for joining us again
today on day two of next so mark I guess
we got one more day left huh one more
day left but I think it's gonna be a
really good day tomorrow
it will be the developer day tomorrow so
expected cool things to happen and if
you're here come by and say hi we're on
Moscone West on the first floor and we
have lots of chocolate we have podcasts
branded chocolates we should come grab
some absolutely you definitely should
have a good one Thanks
great next
[Music]